this video contains spoilers for
everything within the danganronpa
universe except for v3 if you haven't
played v3 than you're safe but be aware
that everything else is fair game enjoy
the video are you asking me to feel
guilty that's a pointless endeavor I
think nothing of sacrificing others for
my own ends I feel nothing that's all
there is to me that's what makes me
complete hello and welcome to dog and
Rampal 101 series of breaks down
everyone and everything in the dark and
Rumble world and today we are going to
be attempting to unravel the web the
ultimate gambler and the queen of liars
Celestia glutton Bourke Celestia luden
burg is a cold and calculative
individual who made up part of the
seventieth class of hopes Peak Academy
Celestia carries herself in a very regal
manner going so far as to replicate
Victorian style mannerisms following a
strict code of etiquette as a lady while
simultaneously looking down upon all
those around her in addition Celestia is
also best characterized as manipulative
exceedingly ambitious and a pathological
liar which is even led to her being
dubbed as the queen of liars as a result
it's actually quite difficult to delve
into Celestia's past on a factual basis
because for example Celestia has stated
that her father was a French nobility
while her mother was a member of a
German family of talented musicians
however we do know that that is
completely fabricated as is her name
Celestia Lunenburg in fact Celestia's
real name is Tycho Yasuhiro and she was
almost certainly born in Japan well
they're probably the most solid piece of
information we know about Celestia is
that she owned a cat whom she named
grand washer eel in Berk the
pronunciation of which I've probably
butchered because I'm pathetic at French
but Celestia loved him dearly and is
quite possibly the only other life-form
on this world that she values other than
her own at some stage during her
childhood Celestia began to actively
aspire to become European royalty
completely reshaping herself in terms of
appearance and personality in order to
fit the role although her grand dream
was oddly more specific than that
as Celestia wished to live in a fancy
castle populated by aesthetically
appealing male servants dressed
exclusively as vampires a simple dream
really but one that Celestia thought
could only be accomplished through the
accumulation of insane amounts of wealth
which brought Celestia to the art of
gambling aiming to acquire as much money
as humanly possible
Celestia found herself in the world of
high
stakes gaming and has even bet her life
on multiple occasions in games like
Russian roulette mahjong in order to
make her dream a reality although I
should say that that is according to
Celestia herself whose words we've
established are not to be trusted under
any circumstances whatever the case
let's see it did come to be a true force
to be reckoned with inside of the
underground gambling circuit and to
became well known for alleviating people
of all of their money and this is the
reputation that caught the eye of coy
chica Sakura a talent scout of hopes
Peak Academy where Celestia was
subsequently offered to place amongst
the 78 class bearing the title of the
ultimate gambler and despite her
established cold and isolated persona
there is evidence to suggest that
Celestia greatly enjoyed her time with
the rest of the class that is until they
would be sealed away within hopes Peak
Academy after the tragedy struck the
world and Celestia had her memories
erased by the ultimate despair and
fellow classmate Junko Enoshima and was
then forced to participate in the
killing school life killing game now one
might say that this environment was more
akin to Celestia's natural habitat and
her studies at hope speak ever were and
she was accustomed to placing her life
on the line for the purpose of games
however this was far from the truth the
Celestia despised being imprisoned
within the academy and was desperate to
escape because she knew that it would
not be possible to achieve her dream in
a place like this regardless less tia
did quickly adapt to her situation going
on to be exceptionally helpful in
deducing the corporates of the first two
class trials and even adopting a
manservant in the form of her Fumi
Yamada who developed a twisted
relationship with Celestia and even came
to refer to her as mistress this is
despite the fact that hoof UMI's
interests
allegedly they exclusively in 2d
characters but this relationship would
play a gigantic role in Celestia's
ambition as the third motive revealed
the surprise of 10 million dollars cash
well whoever quote-unquote graduates the
academy aka murders one of their
classmates and gets away with it and
with everything we know about Celestia
thus far it should not be surprising
that this was more than enough to kick
her into action using her keen intellect
to develop a very convoluted plan which
involved manipulating her Fumi into
murdering kiyotaka Amara before going on
to murder her filming herself in framing
Yasuhito hagakure but that said
Celestia's plot was uncovered in the
third class trial after which her regal
mannerisms evaporated and she reverted
to a state of being that was how shall
we say unbecoming of a lady furthermore
unlike the other students of the
seventieth class who became murderers
for the sake of the killing game once
Celestia was found guilty
she showed absolutely no remorse for her
actions insisting that achieving her
dream was paramount Celestia then
willingly accepted her execution stating
that she wanted to be reincarnated as
Marie Antoinette and claiming not to be
afraid well that's a statement simply
becoming the final in a long long course
of lies that Celestia had been telling
her entire life Celestia's method of
execution was called the burning of the
Versailles which a method which began by
lighting a fire around her the king to a
witch hunt before a sudden fire truck
appeared crashing ironically into
Celestia than killing her instantly
so more fun facts about celestial
Edinburg due to her overtly regal nature
Celestia has a habit of ranking men
assigning them a grade between A to F
which is supposedly helpful in decisions
regarding who to turn in to one of her
future servants Celestia's cat grand
GWACs real Uddin burg would become a
feature character in ultra despair girls
as a target of the Warriors of Hope who
believe the cat to be a monstrous demon
mimicking the appearance of an adorable
kitty and finally a truly useless fact
about underwear during Celestia school
life she wore dark undergarments
featuring jewel lace which was said to
give off the distinct hair of a queen
furthermore according to quote-unquote
rumors apparently AC rank human cannot
bear to gaze upon them but that pretty
much does it for Celestia Lunenburg if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general then
please do consider donating to the new
world review patreon because the support
of all the amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes plates on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured in the next danganronpa
[Music]
[Music]